I'm Judd Brown, Exhibits Manager at the American Museum of Science and Energy.
And we're going to show you how a nuclear power plant works.
This is a nuclear reactor and here's where everything starts.
The nuclear reactor splits atoms to produce heat.
The reactor core sends hot water over into the steam boilers.
We now refer to steam boilers as steam generators.
We bring in cooler water down in this section...
...and as the cool water comes into the steam boilers, it's turned into steam.
Steam is routed across this top section which turns the blades of a turbine.
The turbine turns a generator which produces electricity.
That electricity can then be used to supply up to 800,000 people.
Once the electricity is produced,...
...we can use these two systems to cool down our waters so that it can be reused.
Currently in Tennessee, we have two nuclear power plants...
...with a total operating capacity of three units.
Nuclear power plants have a useful life expectancy of some 40 to 50 years,...
...making 'em viable for producing electricity for several generations.
I'm Judd Brown at the American Museum of Science and Energy.
To learn more about nuclear power, visit us here at Oak Ridge...
...or check out our website at AMSE.org.